[Music]
the relationships become even more
precious the older we all get my Full
House family is incredibly precious to
me and to all of us well fast forward to
now and Candace Cameron Bray has
unfollowed her TV sister Jody Sweetin
who showed support for celebs who have
spoken out against Candace for her
anti-gay comments on Saturday Jody
doubled down on her stance sharing Holly
Robinson Pete's post saying when we hear
the words traditional marriage to
describe only one type of marriage it
belittles the love and commitment that
many have for each other we love each
other like family we argue like family
there's really nothing that we haven't
been through together a source tells E.T
quote Jody does not agree with Candace's
remarks and wanted to show where she
stands Candace is upset that Jody chose
to do this in a public way instead of
talking to her one-on-one Jody's rep has
no comment at this time and Candace
didn't respond to our request for
comment and speaking out now this
Chrisley Knows Best star my mom's got
his back and he definitely got hers just
days after Chase Chrisley's parents Todd
and Julie were sentenced to a combined
19 years in prison for bank fraud and
tax evasion the reality star is asking
how loved ones can unexpectedly be taken
from you he shared a post that ended
with this advice about people who matter
most give them your undivided attention
just do it